merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
plusieurs réponses à la question que
vous posez d'abord les faits la surface
en bio à la doubler entre 2017 et 2022
pour atteindre plus de 2,78 millions
d'hectares ce qui fait de la France la
première surface convertie en bio de
l'Europe de l'Union européenne où on
devrait collectivement s'en féliciter
deuxième élément qu'est-ce que nous
faisons nous ont d'abord au travers de
la politique agricole commune au travers
du programme ambition bio une
augmentation de 30 de plus de 30% des
crédits qui vont être alloués à la
conversion en bio troisième élément ce
que nous faisons aussi dans le cadre ce
que nous avons fait aussi en termes
d'accompagnement dans le cadre du plan
de relance pour faire en sorte que l'on
puisse accompagner mieux les
agricultures bio dans la transformation
de leur modèle quatrième élément que je
veux dire le Crédit Impôt bio qui permet
aux agriculteurs biologiques qui sont
déjà convertis de pouvoir maintenir leur
activité on est passé de 75 millions
d'euros à 109 millions d'euros de 75
millions d'euros à 109 millions d'euros
alors par ailleurs nous avons un sujet
structurel et un sujet conjoncturel le
sujet de conjoncturel c'est le sujet de
l'inflation
qui pèse effectivement sur les ménages
même si comme ça a été dit par plusieurs
collègues on a une inflation plus basse
que d'autres et donc il y a une
dégradation dans les choix des
consommateurs de produits bio vers
d'autres types de produits et donc on a
besoin de travailler sur ce sujet là
puis on a un sujet structurel c'est
l'offre s'est développée il faut que
désormais la demande soit au rendez-vous
nous avions une croissance à deux
chiffres sur les produits bio peut-être
que cette croissance n'était pas atteint
sa limite et donc nous avons besoin de
travailler sur la demande et à faire en
sorte que dans une stratégie de
communication nous puissions montrer les
vertus des de l'agriculture biologique
dans le modèle agricole français puis
par ailleurs vous me permettrait de dire
cessons d'opposer les modèles les labels
la haute valeur environnementale le bio
tout ça et la complétu de l'agriculture
tout conventionnelle c'est la complétu
de l'agriculture française il faut
respecter l'ensemble des producteurs et
faire en sorte que chacun puisse trouver
sa place en termes de rémunération
je vous